Mày 22,5 năm, ngày 19, Mày Xí Cô đã từ dịch Nen Mày Xí O' O' Sê Góra, bây giờ em em chô,
xin nămu nghìn chính trăm số Mày Xó, thu lĩnh bằng đảng Mát Tuy Sê Xí nờ người lớn nhất nước này,
sau khi cơ quan tình báo lần theo dấu phép bạn gái của ông ta.
Theo bộ chừng có phòng Mày Xí Cô, vì các đồ chơi bía là trước khi cuộc đột kích sĩnh ra,
các đặc buổi đã sát định được một người thân tín với bạn gái của ông Chúng này.
Hôm 22,5 năm, ngày 19,5 năm, đặc buổi phát hiện huy vụ nước đựa tới ta của ba,
của nghìn giữ vệ nguy ở Zalisco để gặp O' Sê Góra, sau khi bạn gái dây,
O' Sê Góra vẫn ở lại đây cùng đựa cận vệ, các mình sĩ nhiên trong bao vầy,
giù vất phải khẳng cụ gưới lịch, đưa cận vệ của L-Mên Chô đã bán chú một chức thăng
con sự khiến nó phải hạc kánh hình cấp xuống căn cứu gần nó.
Chó cũng đấu xuống, các mình sĩ đã bán bị thương O' Sê Góra cùng hai cận vệ.
Cả bá được chức thăng đưa đến một bệnh vệt ở Washington,
như đều tự vong trên đối đi.
Thì thế sau đó, đự vong máy bài đến México, C-T và bán ra cho văn phòng tổng tổ.
Bộ chừng anh in của mà gác xia Hà Phu Chó biết, Thì thế O' Sê Góra sẽ được chuyển cho ra đi.
Chuyến thông vi và O' Sê Góra là chúng mắt tuy quyền lực nhất México.
Sau khi được thình lập năm 2018, bằng đảng C-Z nơi vừa của ông ta đã chờ thành một trong những tổ chức buồn mặt tuy và lực nhất nước này,
theo bộ tư pháp Mỹ, Washington, L-Sê G-Nơi vào dân xét tổ chức khủng bố với các bộ tận chuyển của cãi Nguyen.
Đóiên, Mét Tham phê Tamín và Phen Thành đến bỏ lãnh của Mỹ.
O Sê Góra bị tư sử dưới lúc Mỹ từ xa app để México trận sống trẻ mát tuy, đặc biệt là Phen Thành.
Bởi nó ngay, tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng chân nhiều lần đàn xóa tối với hàng hoán như khổ tuy Mỹ.
Chắc rằng người đồng cấp Claudia sẽ bám chưa làm đủ để chúng lại hoàn độc buồn mát tuy.